سبب اخر لازمه الزراعه غلق البنوك في
الخرطوم بسبب النظام المالي المركزي لم
يحصل المزارعون السودانيون على التمويل
وحتى ان وصل الان فقد فات الاوان الفصول
الزراعيه لا تنتظر عدم حصول مزارعين على
التمويل جعلهم غير قادرين على شراء البذور
والاسمده والمبيدات في الوقت المحدد
وبالتالي 40% من احتياجات الحبوب في
البلاد المهدده الازمه الزراعيه امتدت
لتضرب قطاع الدواجن هذه المره ليس بسبب
البنوك المغلقه بل بسبب ان اغلب مزارع
تربيه الدواجن تقع في محيط الخرطوم
وبالتالي تضررت سلاسل امدادها
فتوى في حكم المؤكد ان الموسم الزراعي
القادم في السودان سيتاثر بصوره بالغه في
ظل توقف النظام المصرفي والشلل الوزارات
والمؤسسات الحكوميه ذات الصله بالقطاع
الزراعي وعدم قدرتها على الحركه والتنسيق
لتوفير الاحتياجات فضلا عن نقص العماله
وصعوبه حركتها في ظل تعقد الاوضاع الامنيه
واستمرار الحرب الدائره حاليا بالبلاد
وبحسب معلومات العربيه فان ولايه الخرطوم
والمعروفه بانتاجها البستاني الوفير حازت
النصيب الاكبر من التاثر والضرر فالحدائق
البستانيه فيها والبيوت المحميه تعرضت
غالبيتها للعطش نتيجه انقطاع خدمه المياه
وتذبذب التيار الكهربائي فضلا عن الضرر
بمزارع انتاج الاعلاف والدواجن ويبدو ان
اقليمي دارفور وكوردوفان ستواجه الزراعه
المطريه فيه مصاعب جمه نتيجه التوترات
الامنيه واذ لا توفر لاحصائيات رسميه توضح
حجم الضرر في المجال الزراعي في السودان
لهذا الموسم يتضح ان بعضا من عوامل نجاحه
باتت مفقوده
لكن ما الذي جعل المزارعين يعتمدون
اعتمادا كليا على البنوك من اجل زراعه
حقولهم السر في احداث العام الماضي بينما
كان العالم يعاني من ازمه غذاء بسبب حرب
اوكرانيا ادت الارتفاع الاسعار في الاسواق
العالميه لمستويات قياسيه كان السودان
يعاني من كساد المنتجات الزراعيه وسنعود
الى الجضارب كمثال اضطر المزارعون لبيع
منتجاتهم بالخساره السمسم مثلا لم تغطي
اسعاره في السوق الى 60% من تكلفه الانتاج
اما بخصوص التمور فقط كان الوضع كارثيا
اسعار البيع لم تغطي حتى تكلفه الجنين
ولهذا ترك التمر في النخيل حتى فساده وهنا
لعبت البنوك دورا سلبيا اخر بسبب مشاكل
التسويق باتت البنوك ترفض تمويل مزارع
سمسم والتمور وحتى المستوردين في الجضارف
ايضا اصبح امام التاجر
عشره مشترين للمنتجات الزراعيه بدلا من
مئه في عام 2021
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات